i think that what we're going to see
we're going to see that software will
continue
to be kind of the main destruction on
all every industry
but at the same time we're going to see
less and less issues happens
you know less and less frictions in the
deployment
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with loamy tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel stanford
software is eating the world and raziel
tobin the founder and ceo of code fresh
is helping make it happen
raziel is the founder and ceo of code
fresh a cicd platform designed to help
teams confidently ship cloud-native
applications faster
prior to code fresh raziel had over 15
years of experience building software
and running products in hp
mercury and more an entrepreneur
technology enthusiast and a software
builder at heart
brazil holds an mba from barline
university in israel
and a ba in math and computer science
good morning raziel tv all the way from
california how are you
good morning good morning i'm good about
yourself
i'm doing just fine i we reflected just
a second ago but
you know actually my first visit to code
fresh by accident back in
in mountain view but that was your old
office right i think you you had a
little upgrade since then
yeah we we moved all doing during these
times you don't really see offices that
much you know i'm here alone
by now but hopefully this will come back
i love it and there's so much to talk
about and so many insights that i have
to
extract from you about you know the
world of continuous integration and
deployment
where software is taking us and not you
know what the software is actually doing
but how we build great software
in collaborative teams remotely at scale
all those incredible questions that your
company called fresh is answering
and you're backed by some of my favorite
investors red dot ventures in viola
among others and and i think that the
the journey that you're that you're
going through is just incredible and i'm
a
i'm an avid customer myself and i just
love the product and it's
an honor for me to speak to
entrepreneurs that build the products
that i just
love using on a daily basis and brazil
so before we get started just tell me a
little bit about yourself and
and a little bit about the journey which
is pretty fascinating and you
did quite a lot of things before you
started code fresh
yes i think that you know it's um i'm
really
doing what i really love now because i
you know in my background in my
experience i've been predominantly a
developer as like a software engineer
that's where i started that's what i
study
um and then at one point moved to
product management and you know it's
amazing to see how over the times really
software becoming
you know the main factor what's
disrupting every industry
and as you know i'm moving to product
management
you know i remember back then you know i
started in mercury and then moved to u.s
baccarat
and then at one point you know i was
seeing a lot of the changes that are
going on and how
software you know containers and all of
these technologies comes up and actually
the main goal was to allow
software to be built and deployed even
faster
and um you know even from this large
company really wanted to build that then
in hp
and got like huge fundings and
engineering and all of that but
what really happens in this large
organization is that
things things moves very slowly and and
i remember you know end of um
end of the year of 2013 uh when it was
like the um
the holidays time the shutdown and i was
like sitting there
in miami and i got a phone call from
this high executive managers and hp was
actually telling me listen uh we're
large company we're struggling with
legacy products
and we can't really afford this new an
innovative project within hp anymore we
have to shift the resources back to
legacy
product and i was walking around you
know
i'm frustrated for a little bit and then
you know i remember i called the first
manager that actually funded it within
hp and i told him listen um
it's such a pity this project that i so
believed in
it's been put on hold and he was saying
you know what i how about i give you
like you know 25 000
well just go and do it yourself and you
know back then you're thinking you know
oh my god what i can build with twenty
five thousand dollars you can build the
world with twenty five thousand dollars
that can be
amazing you know and i'm walking around
there in there like in the fountain blue
hotel in miami
and then i'm sitting in a coffee place
they're thinking about should i do it or
not
and the name of the coffee place is like
fresh and as i was thinking about it
you know i i just can't do that you know
and i called my you know my
my co-founder oleg who was um having
having the engineering back then i told
me let's just go and do it
and you know and since then it's just
been an amazing journey because we truly
believe that you know as you said
software is disrupting every single
industry
and you know even you know you're
thinking about it during these coffee
times how people can
still connect and work and collaborate
and it's all you know
there's so many things you can say about
software but this is it's so enabling
our kids to go to school even though you
know from remotes um ourselves to work
people to connect and so on which is
amazing to be part of this
transformation
being building platform that allow
organization
to innovate faster to um
streamline software development faster
and so on so that's you know in a very
very nice field
i think that one of the most incredible
things that i've you know come to
understand this past year now and to
quote
mark andres and software is eating the
world right it's not
even disrupting it it's eating the world
as it is eating it all with one bite
and i think that one of the things that
surprised me most coming out of my five
years
in in the idf was thinking that i
understood you know what software can do
but then
seeing the potential of what's actually
happening and how fast it's going and
how we're not we're barely scratching
the surface
of of how software is going to play an
integral role in our lives
i mean we walk around and we keep
talking yeah technology yeah software
but we fail to understand that we're
we're just in the beginning
of how everything in our world is going
to be directly connected to software
which is why i think
what you're doing is particularly
incredible
it's it is it is amazing you know i
always you know sometimes when i when i
meet with
um people at court fortune many of them
are even younger than me and
and i can't tell them about you know
there were there was a world when we
actually walked to the bank branches you
know it's not that we can do everything
you know for a mobile
there's a day when we when we need to
expand you know um
put an expense report together we used
to collect all the receipts and put them
in a bag and now you can just take
pictures of them you know
think about you know where you are now
in hippo how you like kind of really
disrupting the insurance
industry which was like for many years
something that was so
cumbersome um and now it's just just
become more streamlined and more um fun
to work with and so on so
being the platform that actually you
know enabled it
and and we helping our customers you
know whether it's in the gaming
industry or banking industry or
insurance industry or fintech industry
really
building software faster deploying
software faster introducing you know new
capabilities it's really exciting
so raziel i want to now approach the
teacher and you because i know that
you're teaching about 27 000 students
at udemy uh according to what they saw
so i'm going to ask you now to put on
the teacher hat
and for whoever is not you know in in
tune with
you know the latest developments of and
the terms like continuous integration
continuous development
can you tell me a little bit about the
the past
present and future of software
development how does it happen and
how does you know code fresh with the
continuous integration of
deployments go go is part of this you
know supply chain of
building great software and bringing it
to a product
yeah so i think you know one thing
important to understand is that you know
as as software really disrupting
every industry every technology every
company the technology company
and as you uh wanna innovate with um
technology and with software you
you you're building and you're hiring a
lot of software engineers that are
writing code and building code and so on
and and your your software becoming more
and more complex
and the one thing you know that as we're
living in a world that really technology
it's all about technologies
organizations really seek to kind of
push new changes
and and new features but in the same
times also realize that
when they deploy these new changes they
can't afford that things will break
because their reputation can be you know
so um um can so be broken in a bit you
know you just
get you know your your site is down and
like everyone is talking about in social
media and you lose your reputation you
lose your credibility and so on
so there's always this challenge about
how like i really um
grow and and and make my team velocity
much higher and about you know deploy
software more frequently but in the same
time
i want to minimize the risk i don't want
to introduce changes of vulnerabilities
or things that that will harm my
business
because that that really goes like you
know like fire you know immediately
everyone knows about it and what
codeforce is actually is doing is
whenever a developer is making a change
we're taking that change we're packaging
it we're testing it and then in the end
of the day we're deploying it
and i think that we there there's so
many best practices now that we've seen
from companies like google and facebook
that really build around how to minimize
the risk
of deploying software so for example
one of the very common practice now is
instead of just going and just replace
the
new versions the old version with the
new versions
you kind of get the new version or the
new features that you want to introduce
and you run them
side by side the old version and just
expose it
to some people you know to some
industries to segments
we know that from facebook that
sometimes you know there are new
features that are coming out but only
certain
communities can see that and then like
gradually you expose it to more and more
and more until everyone is safe but that
allows you to
kind of really control the exposure of
these features and if there's any issue
that comes up
you are in a great position to actually
roll back and immediately bring it back
so this way
this practice that you know google have
been working so hard to implement and
netflix
and and and facebook's and so on this is
what we bring in a platform to kind of
allowing every
technology company to implement these
best practices to be able to innovate
to streamline changes faster but in the
same times have full control of
over how they expose and release these
features and being able to mitigate the
risk and roll back
so just to paint a clear picture because
i think that today we're so used to
seeing you know
on the app store every day and getting
another update to another application
right
it's so sick it's so smooth today that
it's that i think to announce that it
may seem that it's so easy
and it's always been so easy yeah why
not just you know write some code and
and you know send an update to all the
users well today
it is easier thanks a lot also to code
fresh but can you
share with me you know from your
experience what is it like you know five
ten years ago
when we don't have these tools to to do
it so smooth so first of all we used to
wait for so long to get
new software and changes that you know
with new features
um i remember back in the day when i
when i was engineering mercury we
released new software like
every year or a year and a half you know
you had to kind of
really wait for so long to get these new
features coming
and it's so exciting that we're living
in a day now that things are moving so
fast we still you know see major
releases
of you know of operating systems coming
up in a year
also time frame but there's also lots of
like mini releases that you we get a lot
of features and a lot of capabilities
and so on
you know when we working with our
customers and you know we closely you
know we
even unicorns um like yourself and and
also like monday.com and we see like how
we all allow them to
really release new features um very
frequently
features can come up on a daily basis on
a weekly basis and so on
this is right in brazil what's actually
something that's a little hidden
is that you know we see sometimes the
big announcements for the updates which
it could be on a weekly basis or once
every two weeks
but the reality is that you know some
companies every hour they
they release something they don't even
announce that it's just happening
because it's so smooth it's not even you
don't have to go on a full-on
celebration because it's part of our
life
exactly exactly exactly and and as you
said being part of it being part you
know with building that platform
that really allows organization to move
fast and and
you know basically to to remain the the
market leaders because if you not
innovate fast if you not move as fast
with technology
you basically lose your on your place in
the market you're not
as leader as you would like to be right
talk to me about the future where are we
heading because things are moving so
fast
what's next i think as things are moving
so far though first of all the uh the
ability to as you said like really
control what's going on because they're
always
things and human mistakes that happen
they're always issues that
that are being introduced and and being
able to allow organization to really
figure out using machine learning what
potentially
can go wrong and then using this machine
learning you identify these issues and
the uh the software will auto roll back
will not wait for the issue to happen
it will just predict the issue that it
will have but that it is about to happen
and then roll back you know um
automatically and alert
uh the engineers and the devops so i
think that what we're going to see we're
going to see that software will continue
to be kind of the main destruction on
all every industry
but at the same time we're gonna see
less and less issues happens
you know less and less frictions in the
deployment
you know because we we don't like we
always like to kind of you know get an
early exposure to this
new um ios or whatever it is but how
frustrating when the thing stops working
and so on
so i think it's it's um
it's even amazing to see how our
expectation from software
is increasing over time you know we were
like much more
tolerant to issues that happened um in
the past and we have
much less patience now you know if
things don't work we just
right away we move to someone else you
know we move to some other product so
um our platform wants to
our customers to move fast but also to
predict issues from uh
from happening and and mitigate risks
before they actually um occur
so perhaps you know most interestingly
in some
capacities you are educating the market
on another capacity you know
the market is getting educated naturally
because you know
if i'm saying that my friend developer
and other companies develop is releasing
more quickly than i am then
then i'm wondering why and i'm fixing it
and obviously there's
the value that you're creating is so
obvious right i mean there's very little
an explanation that needs to be
done in order to understand the value
that you're creating nevertheless
is it easy to just you know integrate
into other companies how much
explanation do you actually have to do
to you know tech leaders to to explain
what you're doing and why code fresh is
the right
is the right tool for them i think
you know um it's getting i thought it
would be like harder
than it actually is because when you
come
into yeah it's good when we come to
organization and you know
it seems like still majority of the
organization they would like to move
faster than they actually move
they they actually see the battle necks
that they have with devops
um you know there are lots of you know
think about it as like if
all of these cars wants to go let's say
here from palo alto to san francisco but
i have only one lane
it's how frustrating it is you kind of
want to build a platform that will allow
you to build more lanes and really
streamline
the uh um the traffic from one place to
the other if i can like you know to some
level use this
this metaphor and that's very same uh um
and that's it's very similar when you
come into organization and tell them
about how fast do they want to deliver
software
but in the same time you also in the
very same time also tell them about
how much they would like to avoid risks
because in in in many cases you know
there is this conflict in organization
though the people who really want to
streamline
deployments and other people who it's
working don't touch
you know i'm really really really
cautious and i don't want anyone to
touch my production because
it's working right and it's not working
you know i have goals about how you know
the sla
and it's working 99.99 of the time
so how do you bring a platform that
gives organization this confidence
that they can streamline more
deployments more software deployments
but in the same times have this control
over this deployment so at any point of
time the machine will identify issues
before they happen and will roll back
that's uh that's a message that
resonates with almost every organization
because again
everyone wants to differentiate now by
by software whether it's airlines
or or banks or insurance companies or
you know fintechs or
any other industry right so i think that
one of the most interesting insights
that i'm
taking from this is that at the end you
know writing great software deploying
great software it comes down to
the same foundation right it comes down
to the same best practices
the same mechanisms that are both you
know predicting whether something will
go wrong or having a test suite that
does it for you
and then having you know this this
figure in the middle
that is able to maintain all of that so
that you don't need you know have
different devops you know colliding and
and keep and keep changing and looking
at what what the world is doing you have
a company like code fresh that looks at
the world says okay we understand the
best practices
partially because we get feedback from
all of our customers and so you're
getting
the benefit of all the insights and all
the you know
either failures or successes we had with
previous clients exactly and
and we also we're bringing it from a
unique position because you know that's
what we do
in codewash we're building these
platforms and it's important really for
startup to really
kind of frame what is it that you do so
we we build this platform and we're
focusing on building this platform
that's really streamlined
you know the deployment of software but
at the same time as we're building just
that we're giving
organization the flexibility they need
to say okay
i want to today deploy my software to
amazon tomorrow to google i will have
the flexibility to shift also to
microsoft like really not being
locked to one vendors simple like other
tools there's so many great independent
software vendors at the moment you know
for
you know there's some companies that
like to work with these vendors over the
other and so on so building this
bus of deployment that seamlessly
integrate and giving the organization
the freedom to choose which which
tools and which platform they want to
work and yet still
help them to streamline the changes
that's a key value because we we are
living in
in a world that software is moving so
fast and so many great tools are coming
so many great platforms
and you want to keep the options to
yourself to really choose at any point
of time the best of free tools and piece
them together
i love that raziel when we just started
this conversation you said how lucky you
are and how
uh and how you just love what you do and
you love
you know uh going to work and you love
building code fresh
what does it come down to does it come
down to the the leadership aspect does
it come down to the
solving a problem that you really care
about what is it
at the very very core i think it comes
down to people
like i really love uh people i really
love to work with people
and and it's amazing to see you know as
both as you're building company and also
you're building customer base and you're
building you know a great supporter a
community you know on the board you work
a lot with people
and and i love doing that you know i i
love doing that and i can do that day in
and day out you know over the weekend
really kind of working with people um
um get people to um
really believe in in what you are being
part of this journey
it makes it just you know kind of
elevated because you're not
alone in this journey there's so many
people that you work with and and i
really love it
like it's it's i can't even tell how
how exciting it is to work with people
and and
and it's amazing brazil i have to say
that it it shows very very clearly and
this is a perfect take with you the most
important question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
i think it is this like i love people
i'm i love people
i love building things with people um
and and there is no other place than you
know i think what i'm doing now
you know um i think that i love building
what we do with the people and
working with people helping them solve
the problem that's
that's what i like doing that's what
thank you very very much i i look
forward to using your product in about
30 minutes when i'm back to work i
appreciate it very much thank you very
much and
stay safe thank you bye